when a filmmaker is making their movie
what should they keep in mind regarding
making it and making sure that they get
a distribution deal are there things
that they should target making the film
changing certain scenes that they know
that distributors are gonna want let's
suppose they have their goldmine genre
they realize what they're making and who
that audience might be but in terms of
securing a distribution deal are there
certain things they should be aware of
in making a film there are a lot of them
aren't the obvious things in the sense
of film makers for the most part tend to
focus on the movie the movie the movie
and some of them the more astute ones
will definitely put some time into
trying to find a name talent to put into
the film but there's a lot of paperwork
and a lot of other details that go into
the delivery process of getting a movie
to a distributed it become very
important having all your agreements in
place with your talent having all you
know locations cleared having you know
copyrights to everything but also having
things like music cue sheets transcripts
there's a lot of these fine details that
are in what are called material delivery
lists which are basically when you sign
your movie over all the stuff you have
to give to the distributor's so that
they can extrapolate and make any create
no any any type of file spec that any
buyer in the world might want you have
to be able to give that to them so that
they're not incurring any costs on that
back end that's really your job as a
producer the old vision is you know the
el Mariachi you know I can make a movie
for seven eight thousand dollars and
sell it and while that's true that that
sort of happened it was also a long time
ago and more importantly the company
that bought it had to invest a lot of
money in finishing it and completing it
and getting the audio fixed and getting
the image fixed and a lot of that stuff
to make it market ready
companies aren't willing to do that
anymore because the model of supply and
demand there's a ton of supply and
there's focused demand so maybe if you
nail that demand they'll help you out a
bit but it's not going to be much and so
you really have to be
you know aware of what's your
responsibility to cover and there's a
lot of great resources on it if you just
google around so music cue sheets and
transcription so with the transcription
is someone just transcribing it to
English and then they're taking that
file and then it can be easily done into
any other language correct like like in
addition to that so it's like it's not
the shooting script it's actually the
verbatim word for word what is said but
more importantly there's timecode on the
page so you have a ballpark of what time
in the movie it's being said and that's
for subtitling so that when they
translate all the subtitles all those
cues they know about where it's supposed
to hit in the movie when they're
creating it there's also things like
when you're doing the audio mix doing
what they call M&E tracks where you
separate out you have your stereo mixed
tracks and then you have these other two
tracks that are all of the sounds and
music of a movie but if you're watching
it and you just have those two audio
tracks playing every single time
somebody speaks their mouth moves and no
words come out that's because we've
wiped out all the audio and the reason
is so when you dub it in a foreign
language
they only dub the audio the verbal they
don't have to dub the whole movie and
remix the whole movie they just dump in
the voice interesting okay so you think
you've got to make it ready for that
kind of stuff that kind of thinking
because that's the way distributors
think right and then the music cue sheet
what would that be about a music cue
sheet is a lot of broadcasters
internationally every single time of
music pieces used that's affiliated with
you know BMI ASCAP or one of the you
know whatever you call them Union so to
speak that the artist is given their
fair share of the royalty because their
music is being used to sell a product
okay so these are all a lot of it's
legal a lot of its documentation a lot
of its just stuff that you kind of have
to showcase again not to protect well
you should have it to protect you and
your making the movie but also to
protect the distributor so that they
know they can engage with your project
in the marketplace and they're not going
to have any issues later on
you